♪ ♪
>> Sean: MORE REACTION TO ALL
OF TONIGHT'S BIG BREAKING NEWS
ON THE COMMENTS BY
MERRICK GARLAND TO THE AG AND
ALSO THE GROWING EFFORT INSIDE
THE BIDEN AND DOJ CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW PROFESSOR FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JONATHAN TURLEY.
YOU'RE A PRETTY FAIR ARBITER,
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT AND WE DON'T
AGREE ON EVERYTHING.
YOU CALL THEM AS YOU SEE THEM,
CALLING BALLS AND STRIKES AND I
GIVE YOU CREDIT FOR THAT.
THERE'S NOT MANY OF THE MEDIA
THAT YOU DO.
YOU TELL ME IF I'M WRONG IN MY
THINKING.
AFTER ALL THAT WE WENT THROUGH
WITH THE FIRST ATTEMPT TO HIDE
DONALD TRUMP THROUGH THE ALPHA
BANK AND TRUMP TOWERS SERVICE
CONNECTED TO THE RUSSIA BANK WAS
A LIE.
IF THEY TRIED TO PUSH THAT ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEN HILLARY PAYS FOR A DOSSIER
THAT MONEY SHE FUNNELED THROUGH
A LAW FIRM THAT HIRED FUSION GPS
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
IT'S DEBUNKED INFORMATION IN THE
DIRTY DOSSIER AND YET THEY WERE
WARNED BEFORE THEY EVER APPLIED
FOR THE FIRST PFIZER
APPLICATION.
IF BUT THEY USED IT ANYWAY.
THEY USED AT FOUR TIMES AND IT
SAYS AT THE TOP OF THE PFIZER
APPLICATION VERIFIED.
THREE WERE SIGNED BY JAMES COMEY
HIMSELF.
YOU THINK OF PEOPLE LIKE
PETER STRZOK AND HIS WORDS THEY
HAD AN INSURANCE POLICY SO
DONALD TRUMP WHEN AND GET
ELECTED.
AM I WRONG?
ARE OTHERS WRONG, OUR GENUINE
DISTRUST OF THE FBI AND THE DOJ?
LOOK AT THE TREATMENT OF PETER
NAVARRO RECENTLY.
THE TREATMENT OF PAUL MANAFORT,
ROGER STONE WHO WE ARE GOING TO
WORK TWO.
AM I WRONG IF YOU ARE A
CONSERVATOR YOU'LL BE TREATED
ONE WAY, IF YOU'RE
HILLARY CLINTON, BIDEN, YOU
COULD TREAT IN ANOTHER WAY?
>> THAT'S PRECISELY WHY THE RAID
SEEMS RATHER RECKLESS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS TO
WEIGH THAT CONTEXT.
THIS COUNTRY IS A TINDERBOX.
HE HAS AN AGENCY IN THE FBI THAT
HAS A DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF
FALSE STATEMENTS, A DOCUMENTED
HISTORY OF MISLEADING COURTS.
YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER THAT BEFORE
YOU APPROVE A RAID OF THIS KIND.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT STRUCK ME
WITH THEIR INITIAL COMMENTS ON
THE SOURCES IS HOW THEY DESCRIBE
THIS.
THEY TOLD YOU THAT THERE WERE
TWO THINGS DESCRIBED IN THE
WARRANT, ONE A GENERAL CATEGORY
OF MATERIAL THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN TURNED OVER TO THE ARCHIVES
UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ACT AND THE SECOND WAS A GENERAL
REFERENCE TO POSSIBLY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
IF THE DESCRIPTIONS ACCURATE,
IT'S VERY CONCERNING.
A FIRST OF ALL, THE FIRST
CATEGORY I THINK YOU HAVE TO SET
ASIDE, IT'S NOT A CRIMINAL
STATUTE OR ORDINARILY ENFORCED
USING THESE TYPES OF
HEAVY-HANDED TACTICS.
ALL OF US WERE LOOKING FOR IN
THE WARRANT AND MAYBE WE WILL
SEE IT IS A SPECIFICITY THAT
THEY HAVE SPECIFIC DOCUMENTS IN
MIND WITH A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
CLASSIFICATION.
DOCUMENTS THAT THE TRUMP PEOPLE
HAD REFUSED TO TURN OVER A
PERIOD OF THAT'S THE SPECIFICITY
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AND THE TYPE
OF THING THAT WOULD LEGITIMATE
BRINGING THIS OR ESCALATING IT
TO A HIGHER LEVEL.
WHAT YOU ARE SOURCES IS NOT
THAT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS WARRANT, BUT WHEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS SPEAKING,
ALL OF US HAD THE SAME REACTION
IN THE FIELD.
WHICH IS WE ARE NOT THAT
INTERESTED IN THE WARRANT AS
OPPOSED TO THE AFFIDAVIT.
THAT'S WHERE WE WOULD FIND OUT
WHAT THE COURT WAS TOLD.
THE WARRANT ITSELF IS SORT OF
THE CONCLUSION TO DESCRIBE THE
PARAMETERS OF THE SEARCH.
WHAT WE WANT TO KNOW IS WHY THE
SEARCH WAS ORDERED, WHAT WAS
TOLD TO THE COURTS, AND DID THEY
REVEAL THAT THERE HAD BEEN
COOPERATION WITH THE FIRST
SUBPOENA?
>> Sean: WE HAVE THE LETTER
FROM FEBRUARY FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND THE DOJ FBI
REPRESENTATIVES WENT TO
MAR-A-LAGO AS LATE AS JUNE.
THE PRESIDENT MET WITH THEM
PERSONALLY AND SAID THEY ARE
WELCOMED BACK ANYTIME AND THEY
REQUESTED A PADLOCK BE PUT ON
THE ROOM WHERE SOME OF THE BOXES
WERE.
THE TRUMP PEOPLE COMPLIED AND
WERE AS HELPFUL AS CAN BE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
AFFIDAVIT AS WELL, BUT WHAT
ABOUT GOING TO A MAGISTRATE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA IS TRASHED, THE
MORALITY OF DONALD TRUMP GIVING
MONEY TO BARACK OBAMA AND ALSO
DEFENDED -- SORRY, I KNOW
EVERYBODY DESERVES A DEFENSE --
DEFENDED PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH
OF ALL PEOPLE JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THE PEOPLE I
WOULD WANT TO GO TO FOR SUCH A
WARRANT LIKE THIS.
>> I THINK WHAT'S SURPRISING IS
THAT THIS WAS HANDLED BY A
MAGISTRATE IN A MATTER OF THIS
IMPORTANCE YOU THINK WOULD GO TO
AN ARTICLE THREE JUDGE OR THAT
THE MAGISTRATE WOULD BRING IN
THE ARTICLE THREE JUDGE TO
BASICALLY CONFIRM THAT THIS IS
THE CORRECT COURSE OF ACTION.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE THAT
AFFIDAVIT AND WE DON'T KNOW.
THEY MAY HAVE FOUND CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
HAS THE RIGHT TO RETRIEVE THAT
INFORMATION.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THIS IS A FAIRLY COMMON CONFLICT
BETWEEN FORMER PRESIDENTS AND
THE ARCHIVES.
MATERIAL IS TAKEN ALL THE TIME
THAT THE ARCHIVE SAYS NEEDS TO
BE BROUGHT BACK.
AND EVEN FURNITURE HAS BEEN
TAKEN OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT DIDN'T BELONG TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENTS.
THIS IS NOT THAT UNCOMMON AND IF
THEY FOUND THOSE TYPES OF
DOCUMENTS, THE QUESTION STILL
REMAINS.
WHY COULDN'T YOU HAVE DONE THAT
WITH A LESS INTRUSIVE MEANS?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TODAY SAID
THAT THERE WAS NO OTHER POSSIBLE
OR LESS INTRUSIVE MEANS.
THAT LEFT A LOT OF US SCRATCHING
OUR HEADS LIKE I CAN TO GIVE A
LOT OF ALTERNATIVES AND THIS
WARRANT HOPEFULLY WILL EXPLAIN
WHY YOU DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS
ANY OTHER POSSIBILITY.
BUT IT'S REALLY THE AFFIDAVIT
THAT WILL TELL US WHETHER THEY
HAD A GOOD FAITH BASIS.
>> Sean: OR